back on Ralph many churches are taking
in Syrian refugees but Trump has called
for a ban on Muslim immigration what
side do you take on that issue I think
that we ought to take a serious look at
who's coming in before we decide who
comes in I think I know personally
Christians who have had to flee Syria
and are saying it there in Lebanon or
there in Jordan I have a humanitarian
organization that I have good friends
that support and they've had to to get
out of there because it's a war zone on
the other hand you've got a lot of
Islamic fighters and some really bad
people in Syria so it's a very tough
issue and I don't know how as people are
entering how you're going to be able to
tell exactly good from the bad it's
going to be difficult you can't heart
issue you can't tell what's in
somebody's heads we have a pretty
thorough vetting process I mean it's
like you cannot vet more the inside of a
person's mind that's right you can't but
I mean they take extraordinary amount of
resources and time to do as much
background as they can well if you look
at the sand but when you look at the San
Bernardino killers in Libya land they
weren't recently from Syria no but
people know that but so are good they
were people who had been radicalized and
we're communicating with people online
and we didn't know it with immigration
no I didn't say it did hate speech that
happens from people like Donald Trump
who when he died
are you can William San Bernardino and
all five members you know on Donald
Trump but but there the facts exists
that when you encourage racism toward
the Muslim community in the United
States the backlash is more
radicalization but uh two things I think
we're seeing here between first row rap
agree I know you know your New Testament
I try know it a little bit too but I
don't remember Jesus ever talking about
carefully vetting people before you have
them come to your table that's not an
important
second of all but it's I'm not saying
it's unreasonable Bill's question was
about churches in the role of the church
and in doing those things and the the
the second point I think that that needs
making always about this stuff is we do
have a system in place you were saying
you were saying as much wait it's this
is not an emergency in that way and
let's always remember one thing that
came up this week I don't know if
everyone saw it was about polling in
1939 about allowing Jews from Europe
into the United States and what
everybody said huge majority was we have
to vet these people very carefully
because we don't know if we can trust
them or not and huge numbers we're never
allowed into this country with the
results we know so we have a good
tradition in our country we're welcoming
welcoming people and letting know and a
bad tradition we're letting millions of
Muslims into our country we have hilly
amel yes yes letting millions yeah well
new urea or not we have a very very
large indonesian muslim community all
right wait wait wait museum muslim wait
wait you said we're let it in do it yeah
absolutely
currently letting in miller they're
coming from the Middle East they're
looming from Asia there I don't think
millions is the correct number I think
it is
I don't forgot it annually I'm not
saying annually but overall but but yeah
they're absolutely coming in and no
one's being denied entry into the United
States today honey of P because I their
faith no one I should lose I know but ii
would you be on shortly okay okay i was
good what was going on in 1939 was not
just and these urns about vetting it
wasn't just that right everybody knew
what was going on in eastern europe
everybody and our government was totally
insensitive to what was happening to the
Jews
we turned rescue ships away and it is a
blot in the armies and this balance read
absolutely and having reason and the
reason we did that you're absolutely
right couldn't agree more it but the
reason we did that is because there was
a huge majority of Americans who were
frightened of outsiders and FDR thought
it was politically essential that he not
allow those people in because there was
a a revolt against it from the very same
what were they called
America first errs who's Greg
grandchildren now yeah a movie let's
also not forget that in Middle Eastern
countries there used to be Jew
yeah and they were playing Christian
pretty much well there are still some
Christians although the Christian
community in Iraq has largely tragic
that pretty much ethnically cleansed yes
but all the Jews and by the way all
those Muslim can by the way pretend it's
the Islamists who are doing that of
course they're the ones driving out
they're the ones driving out the
Christians they're the ones who are
threatening to execute anybody that
doesn't convert to their twisted version
of Islam let's be very clear what the
image is
okay can we expect more Prowse got price
gouging on life-saving medication like
the EpiPen hell yes of course we can
because we don't we don't have
single-payer you know I thought we did I
come from that horrible radical
revolutionary country called Canada
where we had socialized medicine and
single-payer for decades and decades and
decades and decades and it's a weird
thing you know if you actually come from
Canada if you've lived in Canada Liberty
is not suppress people's right to
freedom is in no way you even have to
shed blood you take it back Oh totally
totally I said if a child you know we
had children do you have left it was
well actually there take the Canadian
government claims one child and
sacrifices it in order to pay for the
socialized medicine but you know the
simple truth is I have a wonderful
nephew who was born incredibly
prematurely blessed as Kerris not going
to be blessed Lee and cost hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of dollars to care for that
child and his parents had to pay not a
single dollar because that was something
that we understood as a community
responsibility that's a blessing a
blessing and if I might say it's a
Christian blessing feeling always
supported by the church again speaking
is somebody who's a the son of an MD B
was born severely premature at a time
when many who were born I was born six
weeks premature and most people at that
time didn't survive that I'm not gonna
absolutely nothing Oh sellers you
recover just beat just you're recovering
beautiful just feel free to be yourself
don't worry no offense taken
but III believe very strongly that this
that that health care and choices about
health care is too important to be left
to government and I think that a far
better system is to allow the market to
work allow people to choose their own
doctor athlete and the fact is there are
there there are Canadians who have to
come across around it's not relative I
would also say that let me just finish
my boy Jack there are still there are P
I'm not justifying what happened on the
EpiPen that's what happens when I'm are
killing you is because people in the
market is amazing why most cutting-edge
pharmaceutical what can I make my point
yes there's a reason why most
cutting-edge pharmaceutical medications
are not invented in Canada but there's a
reason why they're invented elsewhere
Ralph because the government fixes the
prices and once you do that you kill R&D
budgets you kill innovation and you kill
the discoveries that save lives and when
you assess the progress the EpiPen you
kill the patient
I said
I'm not I made it abundantly clear I'm
not defending the Prowse cap the price
gouging that they did not believe in a
sunset provision that leads to generic
drugs but you could have the government
setting prices and expect people to
submit all I can tell you is I've lived
in Canada which has a single-payer
system
I've lived in France which actually has
a complicated private and public system
together I've lived in the United States
and let me tell you that people in
Canada and France are is a rule far more
satisfied with the way they get medical
care and security they get and their
freedom is not limited in any way it's
this should not be a pool this is not a
left-right issue this is an issue of
common sense right one more question cuz
carries can never baby here in the
United States not in Canada the hubbub
over Hillary's pneumonia a media
creation or wishy being purposely
evasive well I think she is being
somewhat evasive but I don't think it's
a horrible crime to have a malady and
think you know what I'm not gonna tell
anybody because I'll get over it before
they even know I just know they're
totally a catch-22 because she's sort of
caught in this position where he's she's
saying they're saying she doesn't have
enough stamina she's a first woman we
don't have in this country gold in my
year like somebody who was 70 years old
my ministers right that we don't need
what forget we don't even have Margaret
Thatcher I mean she is the first woman
and she is going at Solly's her so she
does I mean you can understand she was
gonna choose top she's gonna power
through except for then I catches up to
her and she's there she couldn't one one
or the other about her secrecy I could
not even cry with credit I'm sorry more
strongly
what has a candidate for president and
as somebody who aspires to the highest
office of the land your priority should
always be the public's right to know
yeah and the minute she was like the
minute Ron I'd finish my point
yeah finisher because she was diagnosed
don't walk into a traffic exactly she
was diagnosed with pneumonia she should
have had her doctor issue a statement
she should have come forward and issued
a statement and if she had done that
bill it would have been her having the
episode that she had at that 9/11
memorial would have never hurt her
no I politically yeah
should have done I think it was wrong I
hear you I think she should have found a
doctor who wrote a letter saying she
would be the most like a medical daytime
talk show and talked about it I think
that's what you anybody okay I think
anybody who can campaign I think I love
her joke her joke about like well at
least finally now Republicans are paying
attention to women's health a deeper
issue which we none of us want to look
at is is there's no real correlation
between how healthy a president is and
how well they perform FDR let us
remember was in a wheelchair JFK was
seriously ill throughout his president
woodrow wilson would be an exceptional
which we will tonight be might be an
exception that although message i'll
send out my although mrs. wilson
actually did a decent job in that hey
adam that leads to bill i'd stay away -
yeah not the worst possible here would
be another area and the other thing i
think worth saying is that what Hillary
has the pneumonia can be cured what
Trump has apparently cannot be well
you